und bei mir jetzt die
bundesumweltministerium svenja schulze
von der spd an schönen guten morgen herr
und frau schulze sie haben ja gerade
erst gesagt dass seit einer guten halben
stunde wirklich feststeht dass das
gesetz heute im kabinett behandelt wird
gehen sie also davon aus dass das
klimaschutzgesetz heute auch
verabschiedet ja ich gehe davon aus und
bin auch sehr froh darüber weil damit
bekommt klimaschutz jetzt endlich
verbindliche regeln er wird praktisch
gesetz und das ist sehr gut es wird
jetzt so sein
jeder einzelne bereich hatten ziel diese
ziele werden kontrolliert und wir werden
das alles so machen dass es für die
menschen planbar ist man weiß wie das in
den nächsten jahren vorwärts geht aber
auch niemand überlastet wird man muss ja
alternativen schaffen
zu den autos die heute noch mit co2
ausstoß fahren sie haben gesagt das
klimaschutzgesetz soll kontrolliert
werden
das war ja auch ein streitpunkt in den
letzten wochen und monaten werden gerade
die kanzlerin gesehen wie gesagt hat es
muss eine kontrolle geben wie genauso
kontrolliert werden das ist ganz klar
vorgesehen für jeden einzelnen bereich
also für den verkehr für die gebäude
gibt es feste einsparziele und diese
ziele werden von einer experten von
einem expertenrat überprüft ob das
wirklich eingehalten wird und wenn nicht
dann muss der zuständige minister oder
die ministerin sofort handeln muss ein
programm vorlegen wie die ziele denn
dann noch erreicht werden können also es
ist ganz klar und verbindlich geregelt
ihre kritiker sagen dieses
klimaschutzgesetz ist weich gespült weil
einige formulierungen geändert wurden zb
stand in einem alten entwurf im juni
noch dass deutschland bis zur mitte des
jahrhunderts die netto treibhausgas
neutralität erreichen werde sozusagen
ein versprechen und jetzt lesen wir im
aktuellen entwurf lediglich die
bundesregierung wolle dies als ziel
verfolgen also weichgespült oder nicht
nein überhaupt nicht weich gespielt
sondern wir haben aktualisiert weil wir
haben in new york bei dem großen
klimagipfel zugesagt dass wir das tun
wir haben es auf der europäischen ebene
getan und das steht jetzt da drin also
es ist noch eine spur verbindlicher als
vorher wer das hört sich nicht so an
wenn die formulierung stimmen als ziel
verfolgen ist natürlich weicher als wir
legen uns fest dass wir es wollen also
wem haben sie dazu gestellt ist gemein
das ist kein zugeständnis an das erste
mal sah keine regierung in einem gesetz
dass wir mitte des jahrhunderts
treibhausgase neutral werden
werden das als rolle ja aber wir müssen
es doch schrittweise jetzt angehen wir
können das entscheiden aber das passiert
doch nicht von alleine sondern das
klimaschutzgesetz und die ganzen
maßnahmen die wir jetzt vorliegen die
beschreiben den weg dahin und das ist
das was jetzt passieren muss nur schöne
worte das hatten wir über viele viele
jahre
jetzt wird es verbindlich jetzt wird das
gesetz man muss nur mal konkret wie
verbindlich ist das klima paket ganz
konkret co2 reduktion um 70 prozent bis
2040 und klimaneutralität bis 2050 wird
das so drin stehen es steht drin 2050
klimaneutral und das bis 2030 über 20
jahre zu planen ist gar nicht so einfach
deswegen haben wir für die nächsten zehn
jahre für jedes jahr ein ganz
verbindliches ziel für jeden einzelnen
bereich und dann sollen wieder neue
ziele festgelegt werden ich hoffe dass
wir besser sind als wir bisher zugesagt
haben und darauf wollen wir dann auch
aussagen des herrn vielleicht können sie
ein bisschen erklären wie die
verhandlungen so laufen weil zum
beispiel als wir jetzt gestern abend die
sendung vorbereitet haben war noch nicht
klar ob das gesetz im kabinett sein wird
das klimapaket vor ein paar wochen da
haben sie nächtelang in der koalition
verhandelt warum dauert das alles so
lange warum werden da dann vielleicht
auch so übermüdete entscheidung
getroffen für manche sieht das alles
bisschen unprofessionell naja das neue
ist dass aus dem bett seiner
verantwortung der gesamten regierung ist
früher war dazu da für die
umweltministerin zuständig die musste
immer allen auf den füßen stehen und
sagen jetzt macht doch endlich was ja
weil das handeln liegt ja im
verkehrsministerium im bauministerium
jetzt sind alle unmittelbar
verantwortlich jeweils für ihren bereich
für den klimaschutz und das ist etwas
komplett neues das gab es bisher so
nicht und deswegen ist das auch gar
nicht so einfach umzusetzen weil jetzt
jeder liefern muss jeder einzelne
minister
also es wird deutlich verbindlicher
klimaschutz ist jetzt gesetz zum schluss
nur eine frage zu den klima protesten
hier in berlin extension rebellion
besetzt hier die kreuzung paar kollegen
sind auch heute später zur arbeit
gekommen hier in berlin was halten sie
von dieser art des klima protest ich
freue mich erst mal wenn er ganz viele
menschen wie bei friedersdorf user dafür
kämpfen dass es mehr klimaschutz gibt
ich denke nur dass wir aufpassen was
das polarisiert sich im moment sehr
stark die die auf jeden fall dafür sind
und die die ganz dagegen sind in die
wahrheit ist aber in der mitte wir
müssen die gesamte gesellschaft
mitnehmen das ist eine demokratie hier
wir müssen überzeugen und das will diese
regierung und das ist etwas wo ich finde
da muss die diskussion auch insgesamt
ein bisschen leichter werden wir müssen
alle menschen in diesem land mitnehmen
klimaschutz ist nicht nur eine
angelegenheit für wenige sondern für
ganz viele sagt svenja schulze von der
spd bundesumweltministerin und das
klimaschutzgesetz kommt heute ins
kabinett wann geht's los 38 39 39 alles
klar vielen dank dass er heute da war
danke auch tag